godzilla vs kong the most anticipated
movie of 2021
this movie had been in the shadows ever
since godzilla kotm was released
everything was shady and we had no idea
about plots or even if it was gonna be
finished
but since january this year we have had
quite a few teasers tv spots and a
trailer
and one main question that comes to mind
is who is the real villain of
the movie we already know that there
would be kong godzilla
warbat mechagodzilla and a couple of
other creatures and characters in
our groups in it but who is the main bad
guy
well let's dive into what we know and
make a best guess
of who will be the main villain in the
showdown let's get down to it
at first we have kong we have seen quite
a lot of
kong in the trailers and teasers and we
can definitely say
that this titan would be the good guy
and he has always been so in his
previous movies
other than the unintentional destruction
he might cause he is still on the side
of humans and
he would definitely be needed for the
world to survive as stated by the
characters of the movie
next we have godzilla the big g has been
portrayed as a protected titan
and one who brings balance to the
natural order but in the footage we have
seen
there is no sign of this except for the
fact that madison russell believes that
something else is provoking him to
attack
we see glimpses of the destruction being
caused by godzilla
whether in the city or the convoy of
ships that was carrying kong
and even in the map of the world we can
see that godzilla had been attacking
monarch
and apex bases all over the world for
some reason but is he bad
well not really godzilla is a good guy
in the monsterverse and it would be
surprising that he would turn bad all of
a sudden
after kotm i believe he is doing his own
thing and searching and destroying
something that is posing as a threat to
the world
and him as an alpha titan so no godzilla
isn't a villain
but he is causing a lot of havoc though
so what about the warbat on nuzuki they
resemble giant cobras with
10 yet long bodies and greyish brown
skin their elongated ribs can extend the
legs skin
and create a red hood-like structure
that can be used as wings
they can use these wing-like hoods to
fly and we see kong battling a couple of
these in the hollow earth
they might appear as bad guys or savage
predators in their natural habitat
but even though we hope that this would
be like a god titan before
we can clearly see that kong is easily
handling both of them with ease
so even though they aren't the good guys
they definitely are not the main
villains of the show
then is it mechagodzilla well the
mechanized iron is often portrayed as
humanity's answer to counter godzilla
and it might be the main threat in the
movie he is seen in the first clip of
the trailer as emerging from a hidden
station and immediately causing
a lot of chaos even though it is just a
mechanized titan one that is controlled
by the son of serizawa
it is still a robot essentially and
doing the bidding of ren serizawa
so unless in the latest scenes of the
movie ghidorah's head that is
theorized to be used to power and pilot
the mecca thus awaken and take
control over the functioning systems we
can't see mechagodzilla as the main
villain
but in reality it is still the lingering
essence of the three-headed dragon
ghidorah that should be considered as
the main threat to the world
and the other titans as well now we
can't just shrug aside the human element
of the show
yes this is a godzilla vs kong fight
that is supposed to be the monster
version of batman vs superman
in batman vs superman the two heroes did
have a showdown and doomsday did emerge
and became the main threat later on same
in this one
koh and godzilla would battle and
mechagodzilla would maybe come in
between them
and become the main threat but as in bvs
so shall it be in gvk lex luthor was
actually the brains behind the entire
series of events of batman vs superman
and in this movie it might be ren
serizawa that would be
the hidden evil genius that would throw
a spanner in the works and therefore be
the main culprit of
the battle between these titans and the
mecca so is he the main villain
there is a big chance here so most of us
have forgotten about the mysterious apex
organization that was not in the
previous movies
but only came up in this one just as
alan jonah and the eco-terrorist group
were the main
human villains of kotm apex could be the
successor to this title
it is theorized that this organization
was in charge of robotics and
cybernetics in the monsterverse
and we can see that godzilla had already
been attacking their bases all over the
world
apex and renzerizawa at its helm might
be the main human villains of the movie
and alongside the mechanized starting at
data's utilizing ghidorah as its head
them together would be the main threat
to everyone in the world
so yes they are the main villains we
also have a theory that there would be
an unseen titan
something like a god titan that dwells
in the hollow earth that might be a
grave threat to the entire world
but we have no evidence on it and maybe
it could happen maybe it won't
who knows maybe as a main threat that
would appear in the next monster verse
film
so with that we come to the end of the
video hope you liked it and do let us
know about your thoughts in the comments
section below
do like for support smash that subscribe
button
and also hit that notification bell for
regular updates on master videos
right here on mind cue take care fam
[Music]